you can hey everybody at zach and asha
from the set of sam one part of our set
we can't really show you all of set
because i would spoil everything what it
wouldn't be fun like that explained this
movie in one sentence Asher
it's a fun family movie and it's
everyone's gonna want to watch it yes do
you agree I agree I in one sense I would
say this movie is like Superman meets
big so for most of you you don't know
who Superman is and if you're old enough
and cool enough you know the Tom Hanks
movie big that's kind of what what that
is right I feel like unique you know you
know I love Superman I grew up watching
Superman as a kid and I think him and
super him and Superman we should hold
this anymore
we forgot that a little bit of it we
just kept going with the selfie thing
because you know we're tweens everything
yeah
so yes okay so what makes it unique then
I like I like Shazam because he reminds
me a lot of Superman you can basically
do everything that Superman can do so
that's really well that doesn't make it
unique I think it makes it unique and I
think it makes it unique that it's you
yeah me fourteen-year-old kid right cuz
Superman's an alien from another planet
and you're like oh you're the earth's
mightiest mortal and when you become me
right so I guess I like that all right
next question pick it they're all
stacked on top of each other so there's
not a lot of randomness today let's see
um as a former foster kid having a hero
like Billy Batson exists means the world
to me
how does it feel to be a part of a
superhero project that has a special
relationship of foster care edits oh
that's a good one is it very good well I
think I mean I think that's part of the
uniqueness of the movie - actually I
don't I can't think of just off the top
my head I can't think of other foster
kids who became superheroes within the
comic books there have been orphans
there have been kids with a lot of
family problems that's for sure but I
can't think of anyone in the foster care
we are a second after we want to hear
your best Shazam yo okay you realize
this is gonna be happening for like the
rest of our lives every time you go to a
convention somebody's gonna ask you ok 1
1 2 3
Shazam that's pretty good I don't bring
it about that all right how many times
do you think you have said the word
Shazam since start approach and actually
know the answer
myself how many times you use it every
day every day that's not your real last
person I think was something along the
lines of can you tell us about oh yes
the rest of your family the Shazam Lee
will guess what we can do you one better
people cuz we're gonna bring the whole
show's API here come on we gonna play
Jack grace and faith in Jovan and of
course I like to hashtag Shazam Lee
folks that's that's what I'm calling
anybody else can get that going I'm
gonna hashtag that how do you guys all
enjoy working on the movie now we're
interviewing you guys prepared my Tiger
I think that's our we will wrap it up
guys that's it that's all we've got
[Music]
yeah make sure you go check all that the
Shazam Shazam movies yes handles that
Twitter and Instagram and Facebook and
all of the other social there's so many
now I don't know oh hello don't be
alarmed it's me Henry Cavill sometimes
superhero and former secret agent
but now completely clean-shaven I know
it's hard to recognize me without Kings
- sometimes even have trouble
recognizing myself it's hard for me to
admit this is non CGI he's really gone I
can tell you this though hey everybody
is Charlie really gonna miss that stache
so obviously the Shazam cast did that
big livestream spent like half of it
talking about Superman then mysteriously
Henry Cavill shaves his super stache
maybe in time to film his cameo sometime
soon but I'll just explain a little bit
about some of the Easter eggs they
reveal like they don't really spoil
anything from the film but like the
Tigers they had is actually something
from the Shazam comics
in the background the carnival is
actually relevant to that too like
Zachary Levi is saying that the movie is
going to be like Superman meets Tom
Hanks big if you have not seen big it's
probably one of the best Tom Hanks 80s
movies of all time but if you are
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos
speaking of Superman there's also
Superman stuff happening later tonight
that'll talk about at the end of the
video real quick
but I just wanted to get this out
because they actually do did some really
cool stuff so I might do a separate
follow-up video for this if you guys
want but if you didn't know the movie
itself takes place inside Philadelphia
the Tigers that they're all holding up
and the ones they have strung up in the
background at this carnival that they're
filming this at is Tony the talking
tiger from the Shazam comics that goes
all the way back to the 1940s
Shazam comics has been part of the
Marvel Shazam family for a long time so
not to get too confusing with Captain
Marvel Shazam the tiger debuted when it
was still called the Marvel family and
then they introduced the entire Marvel
family so from left to right you have
Pedro Eugene Darla is the small girl
here Mary Marvel obviously Mary Marvel
is a big character you recognize her
pretty instantly and then this is Freddy
so Freddy was actually seen on set
wearing a Man of Steel logo t-shirt so
if there was any confusion about whether
or not this takes place in the DC
Universe I mean yeah I think we kind of
known that for a while but then wearing
the Man of Steel logo around in the
movie means that they're really tying
Henry cavils Man of Steel to this in a
meaningful way there been a couple of
Gotham Easter eggs the people have
spotted obviously Philadelphia isn't too
far away from where Gotham and
metropolis are inside the DC Universe
but as far as we know they haven't
actually filmed a Superman cameo yet so
that might not happen till way late in
the process and that might wind up being
green screen because Superman will be
doing Superman related things maybe
briefly helping him out or giving him
some sort of meaningful pep talk that
Superman would give to a young child
they have a relationship kind of like
that in the comics Billy Batson wears
his t-shirt around in the animated movie
he looks up to Superman so you can kind
of imagine how they might try to use
Henry Cavill without having him
overpower the movie so I'm not expecting
a ton of him during this but I just I
love the idea that right as this was
happening
henry cavill also posts a video of
himself shaving the super stache like
he's getting ready to
film another Superman scene let me know
what you think about this in the
comments though especially the idea the
tone is something of Superman meets Tom
Hanks big what do you think is a solid
pick if you're gonna have like a
stranger things vibe to this with a
bunch of kids running around or like the
it movie like movies that follow groups
of kids running around doing little kid
things but also then doing the Shazam
part of it where he actually turns into
the idealized version of himself with
all his powers
[Music]
but what will happen is is new Superman
Krypton video posting either later
tonight or early tomorrow if it gets too
late the episode doesn't air till 10:00
p.m. Eastern Time so be sure to find a
way to watch that because I'll be doing
a video for it click here for brand-new
infinity war and click here for that
special Krypton Superman episode thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you